[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est le bon moment
après beaucoup d'années c'est le temps
de
garder mes crampons et de me concentrer
sur une nouvelle page des trois
dernières années j'ai beaucoup moins
joué j'étais beaucoup plus concentrés
sur la sueur et desservir former la
jeunesse dans mon club à chelsea c'était
vraiment là la philosophie c'était aider
les jeunes à jouer et à être performant
et et après aller vendre dans des bons
clubs en europe ou en amérique centrale
et du sud et j'ai aidé mon club faire ça
et donc petit à petit je me rapprochais
du monde d'entraîneur et je m'éloigne du
monde des joueurs est donc là maintenant
j'ai pris ma retraite
comme toujours ma finale en 2013 et on a
gagné on a été champions et ça a été le
haut ne le le pic de ma carrière en 2013
mais on a gagné on a été champion des
états unis et de donner ça une équipe
comme kansas city qui était à l'époque
une petite équipe n'a vraiment changé la
perception des gens sur le kansas
aux etats unis toutes les équipes
championnes vont à la maison blanche on
a eu le privilège de rencontrer obama et
ils voient la machine petit une petite
vanne après ça montre déjà c'était des
mets fin 2014 et ça restera aussi dans
ma mémoire c'était quoi la petite veine
moi c'était par rapport à la manière
avec laquelle j'étais habillé à l'époque
j'avais des magasins de vêtements et
j'avais une foule r&d doute aurait il a
dit aux accueils il venait me ressembler
quand il sortira quand il sortira de
l'office de la maison blanche
thierry henry ça a été un conte exemple
je le connaissais pas du tout et grâce à
la mls j'ai pu rencontrer et le
connaître et que c'est un joueur humble
très professionnels amoureux du football
grâce à l'est mais j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance de côtoyer des grands joueurs qui
même par leur comportement comme kaka
sans rien dire et ils te poussent vers
le haut d'avoir eu la chance de pouvoir
côtoyer des joueurs aussi bons ça ça te
fait que grandir footballistiquement et
aussi comme homme et par ce qu'ils ont
vécu des expériences énorme
aux etats unis c'est accepter on peut
aller jusqu'à 99 donc directement je
suis arrivé à qantas qui j'ai demandé de
78 à je suis né et j'ai grandi à
fontenay le fleury et bien sûr c'est une
fierté
j'espère qu'il y aura beaucoup de
d'autres personnes du 178 qui pourront
voyager autant et voir autant de deux
cultures
je reviens je rentre en europe parce que
je rentre paris madrid et c'est pour me
former en tant qu'entraîneur et
directeur
national directeur général comme on dit
là-bas à manager général et donc ça sera
entre madrid paris et manchester je veux
vraiment étudié pour être
prêt quand les bonnes opportunités
montagne
[Applaudissements]